les anciens Égyptiens se sont donnés
beaucoup de mal pour s'assurer que les
esprits de leurs défunts rois seraient
protégés pour l'éternité
[Musique]
dans les profondeurs de la terre les
pharaons étaient enterrés avec tous
leurs trésors
depuis cette dernière demeure il devait
voyager en paix jusqu'au monde suivant
les Égyptiens croyaient que quiconque
aurait tenté d'interrompre leur parcours
serait victime d'une malédiction
mortelle
la malédiction de Toutankhamon et
légendaire
un pharaon mort depuis plus de 3000 ans
a été réveillé par les archéologues
irrité par cette intrusion le pharaon
prend sa revanche en sortant de son
tombeau pour ébranler les vies humaines
le monde va avec peur les dépouilles du
corps ressurgir c'est une histoire de
mort de destruction de magie et de
mystères et jusqu'à ce jour la
malédiction du pharaon reste inexpliquée
[Musique]
la Vallée des Rois et l'un des
cimetières les plus mystiques du monde
[Musique]
situé tout le long du rivage ouest du
Nil sous l'ombre des falaises abruptes
des dizaines de pharaons égyptiens y
furent enterrés parmi eux certains des
plus grands souverains de l'Égypte
ancienne des hommes qui ont commandé aux
os du Nil de se déverser sur les rives
et nourrir le delta des hommes qui
détenaient le pouvoir et une immense
sagesse jusque dans leur tombeau
Milan avant Jésus-Christ le Grand Empire
égyptien commença à disparaître et à
devenir vulnérable aux attaques
extérieures
les Grecs et les Romains furent les
premiers à prendre le contrôle de
l'empire ensuite durant l'ère moderne ce
fut au tour des Français sous l'armée de
Napoléon et finalement les Anglais
prirent le pouvoir au tournant du siècle
des légionnaires britanniques affluèrent
sur le Nil durant l'occupation de leur
pays
il va pour différentes raisons
l'épictologue Howard Carter était attiré
par la promesse du Trésor ensevelie le
cinquième compte de carnet pour prendre
soin de sa santé
il a eu un grave accident de voiture en
Allemagne qui a énormément affaibli ses
bronches
donc qu'il avait besoin d'un climat
chaud et agréable aussi étrange que cela
puisse paraître l'Egypte semblait faire
la faire
en 1915 les deux hommes s'associaient
à entreprendre d'immenses fouilles
tandis que Carter accepter d'être le fer
de lance de ce projet
à cette époque on croyait que toutes les
tombes des pharaons de la vallée des
rois avaient déjà été localisé
payés par des anciens voleurs de tombeau
les trésors se sont envolés depuis
longtemps
seuls quelques vestiges ont été laissés
de côté
certains d'entre eux convaincuquenter
qu'il y avait au moins une autre tombe à
découvrir
la tombe du roi tout en Camon un petit
Pharaon qui dirigea l'Egypte il y a plus
de 3000 ans
son corps n'a pas été retrouvé il doit
encore être dans la tombe donc il y a
encore une chance pour que la tombe soit
intacte et la notion de trouver une
tombe intacte à visiblement été un grand
espoir pour tout le monde
Carter dirigea une équipe de plus de 100
hommes pour la fouille méthodique du sol
de la vallée après 6 ans de dur labeur
les fouilles n'ont rien donné
le compte carnavone voulait abandonner
la faire
Carter plaidant en faveur du projet pour
une saison supplémentaire
les fouilles reprirent le premier
novembre 1922 durant la matinée du 4
novembre un porteur d'eau cherchant
d'une place élevée pour poser son seau
s'écroula accidentellement
les hommes fouillèrent chaque parcelle
de terre et de cailloux l'une après
l'autre jusqu'à ce qu'il soit bloqué par
une porte plâtrée et scellée
lorsqu'il trouva cette porte et vit
qu'il y avait du plâtre et des sauts de
nécropole Carter était sûr qu'il venait
de trouver la tombe royale
après des années de travail je me suis
sentie au port de ce qui allait être une
splendide découverte
tout nous savions qu'on pouvait tout
découvrir derrière ce passage
[Musique]
et ordonna aux hommes de veiller sur le
tombeau
les fouilles devaient attendre le compte
carnaval Carter envoyé un télégram au
château d'Ikea en Angleterre
insinué que le tombeau était intacte par
le biais de son fameux télégramme
adressé au compte carnaval
de l'un ou nous nous trouvions il
n'avait aucune preuve réelle il a compté
sur son intuition
et je pense qu'il voulait faire venir
carnarbon en Égypte le plus rapidement
possible et c'était le meilleur moyen
pour le faire déplacer
le 23 novembre le conte carnarvone
arriva à Louxor avec sa fille Lady Evin
Herbert
sans perdre plus de temps l'équipe des
fouilles recommence à son travail
une fois de plus les hommes extirpèrent
la terre et exposèrent la porte scellée
Carter examina les sauts et à sa grande
consternation constata que les scellés
avaient été rompus
le tombeau avait été pillé
[Musique]
Carter appuya calmement sur les portes
derrière la première porte se trouvait
un autre passage silencieux et sombre
ces murs abriter les secrets des siècles
passés un mètre plus loin une deuxième
porte celle-là c'est les mains
tremblantes Carter creusa un passage
dans la porte et entra
au début je ne voyais rien l'air qui
s'échappait de la pièce faisait vaciller
la flamme des bougies ensuite lorsque
mes yeux s'habituèrent à la lumière les
détails de la pièce apparurent lentement
derrière le nuage de fumée des animaux
étranges des statuts de l'or leur prière
partout
[Musique]
on fait une découverte historique le
tombeau du roi tout en Camon en dehors
des marques sur la porte il s'est avéré
être intact peut-être que cette
découverte peut résoudre le mystère de
ce roi qui était-il et pourquoi
mourut-il si jeune
nous en savons un peu plus à propos de
Toutankhamon il monta très jeune sur le
trône et il mourut aussi très jeune il
n'a pas régné très longtemps
nous avons une thèse à ce sujet
en fait sa mort n'a pas été naturelle il
a peut-être été assassiné
le monde s'arracha les journaux qui
prétendaient que les trésors du tombeau
de Toutankhamon avait été minutieusement
déterré à un
des bijoux des huiles précieuses des
genres de vins des meubles des chars des
armes et des statues
[Musique]
il n'y a jamais eu autant de trésors
découvert auparavant chaque objet
dissimulé d'un secret promettant de
révéler un fragment d'histoire
parmi les plus fascinants objets
découverts par Carter et carnaval deux
imposantes silhouettes garder les portes
de l'antichambre
c'est sur le dos de l'une des statues
que Carter dit avoir trouvé le premier
de la série des avertissements
le message était menaçant
je suis celui qui refoule les voleurs de
la tombe grâce aux flammes du désert je
suis le protecteur du tombeau de
Toutankhamon
d'après ce qu'on dit Carter n'aurait pas
cru au pouvoir de la malédiction du
pharaon mais sachant que la majorité de
ses ouvriers y croyaient il leur cacha
et le travail continua
il nous a fallu 7 semaines pour déblayer
cet antichambre et merci mon Dieu nous
terminèrent les travaux sans subir
aucune sorte de tragédie
le 17 février 1923 l'équipe se préparait
à casser les scellés de la deuxième
chambre
celle-ci contenait le sarcophage du
pharaon
la foule était impatiente les fouilleurs
et des inquiets
le plus important pour Carter car
Narbonne et sa fille furent la
découverte de la nuit suivante lors de
leur exploration secrète que la tombe
n'avait jamais été visitée
dans la chambre du tombeau et ils ont
regardé ce qu'il y avait ils ont pu
alors constater que le tombeau était
complètement intacte
plusieurs personnes ont pensé qu'il
était déplacés de la part du trio de
rentrer dans la chambre dans le noir et
sans escort effectivement cet acte
marque un point crucial dans la
malédiction une succession de choses
étranges allait se dérouler
un cobra se glissa dans le château de
Carter au bord du Nil il se faufila dans
la cage à oiseaux et l'étranglas le
départ d'un bon présage
selon les anciens textes égyptiens le
Cobra et le protecteur du pharaon la
légende affirme qu'il attaque et qu'il
pique ses ennemis
ceux qui croyaient au mauvais présage
étaient persuadés que Carter et son
équipe avait des problèmes poulet un sol
sacré attiser le pouvoir destructeur du
pharaon
Carter minimisa cet incident car son
équipe est lui avait des années de
travail de vente
cataloguant et préservant les objets
rares il poussa son équipe à continuer
en février 1923 Carter prépare à
l'ouverture de la chambre du tombeau les
journalistes sont venus dans la vallée
pour couvrir l'événement les touristes
firent le voyage afin d'être les
premiers témoins des fouilles des
dirigeants de haut rang louèrent les
deux premières rangées de siège
au milieu de cette excitation le compte
carnarvone se moqua du public
enthousiaste perché sur ses chaises
regardant comme s'il se préparait à
donner un concert dans le tombeau
l'un des journalistes Arthur va égal un
célèbre égyptologue fut surpris par le
commentaire irrévérencieux de carnaval
[Musique]
mon grand-père qui a été impliqué dans
l'ouverture d'autres tombes dans la
Vallée des Rois a toujours vénéré et
respecter les esprits
il a toujours été affecté par le marché
économique créé pour l'ouverture des
tombes datant de 3000 ans
il était très conscient du fait qu'il
découvrait un espace temps mystérieux et
si lointain et je pense qu'il devait y
aller humblement ce que ne semblait pas
faire car Narbonne
puis je me suis tourné vers l'homme à
côté de moi et je lui ai dit si carnar
Von garde cet état d'esprit je lui donne
6 semaines à vivre vegan lance à son
commentaire sans colère à Carter brisa
les scellé de la chambre
il met les murs à nu avant la fin de la
journée la pièce révéla un énorme
tombeau recouvert d'or la dernière
demeure du roi Toutankhamon le public
était sans voix autour du tombeau du roi
il y avait des peintures murales des
trésors éparpillés et les emblèmes de
l'enfer
c'est ici que Carter a dû recevoir son
troisième avertissement celui inscrit
sur un ancien hiéroglyphe sur une
tablette en terre cuite la mort va tuer
de ses ailes qui compte troublera la
paix du pharaon
en dépit de lavertissement Carter se
tourna vers ses invités d'honneur il
évite avancé par 3 à l'intérieur du
tombeau pour être témoin de ce
magnifique mausolée
et j'étais sûr que parmi les personnes
présentes aucune n'oublierait cette
expérience
elle serait gravée dans nos mémoires
nous avons été présents à la cérémonie
funéraire d'un roi mort depuis longtemps
et presque oublié
l'étape suivante était de démonter les
tombeaux cette lourde tâche a pris des
mois une fois de plus l'entrée de la
tombe a été fermée et des gardes postées
devant l'équipe de fouilles planifia de
prendre du repos jusqu'à ce que les
préparations soient achevées et que
l'équipement soit envoyé carte un
travail sur la vallée depuis son château
le comte-caronne
pour se relaxer près du Nil
c'était la dernière fois que les hommes
se voyaient
[Musique]
à l'arrivée du printemps en 1923 les
ouvriers ont nettoyé l'une des deux
pièces du tombeau de Toutankhamon
au milieu des trésors Carter avait
découvert deux anciens messages qui lui
avertissaient d'abandonner le tombeau
[Musique]
la tristement célèbre malédiction du
pharaon était en marche maintenant
c'était un poison à combattre le conte
carnarbonne se relaxer quelques heures
au sud de la vallée des Rois en
attendant les conclusions des ouvriers
mais ces vacances prirent une tournure
alarmante
mon grand-père se rasait à l'ancienne
en se rasant
il s'est coupé
là où un moustique l'avait piqué sur la
joue et ça s'est affecté
il devint soudainement très malade au
moment où il rejoignait le Caire sa
nuque était enflée et il avait de la
fièvre par la suite il contracte à une
pneumonie les docteurs furent incapables
de le soigner
sa femme et son fils verte en Égypte
pour être à ses côtés le conte carnavone
morue le 5 avril 1923 il avait 57 ans
[Musique]
après tout le travail qu'il a fait c'est
triste qu'il n'est pas vu le meilleur du
tombeau ainsi que toutes ces richesses
la mort du conte carnavone était
enveloppée de mystère pas uniquement
parce qu'il était devenu malade et qu'il
mourut les jours suivants mais sa mort
coïncidait avec deux événements
particuliers
selon les témoignages au moment précis
de sa mort le chien de sa famille au
château de high clair cria et mourut
toutes les lumières de la ville du Caire
vasculaires et c'était hier
ils ne se sont jamais demandés pourquoi
les lumières du Caire se sont éteintes
mais cette histoire s'apparenta bientôt
à la malédiction des pharaons
par rapport à ce que nous savons ces
événements ont réellement eu lieu
comment les expliquer ça je l'ignore
les journalistes qui ont couvert les
fouilles savaient comment expliquer ce
phénomène la malédiction du roi
Toutankhamon a été provoquée et
maintenant elle prend sa revanche
les gens étaient abasourdi ils ne
savaient que dire de la mort prématurée
du conte carnaval ou des coïncidences
qui accompagnèrent ce décès même Arthur
vaigal était sous pression pour
justifier la prédiction qu'il avait
faite sur la mort du conte carnavone en
moins de 6 semaines
[Musique]
il ne pouvait rien dire de plus à ce
propos je pense qu'il se sentait un peu
malheureux parce qu'il n'était pas
capable de faire des prévisions il ne se
sentait certainement pas fier d'avoir
dit ça mais il était étonné que cela
soit arrivé et c'était une des curieuses
prophéties qui semblait échapper au
subconscient
l'opinion publique réclama les détails
la mort du chien de la famille à éclair
la coupure de courant au Caire
ils étaient seulement trop disposés à
croire aux malédictions toute histoire
de ces objets des antiquités provoquant
chagrin et peine à leur propriétaire
était arrivé bien avant l'histoire de
Toutankhamon et mon grand-père a
toujours été l'écrivain de ces histoires
terribles que les gens racontaient il
disait que même après leur vie était
maudite
l'esprit du roi toutankhamon est
vraisemblablement resurgit de son
tombeau et a pris sa première victime
qui allait être le suivant
[Musique]
bien que très affecté par la mort de son
mécène et ami Carter décida de terminer
les fouilles et de remonter le trésor et
la momie de l'ancien Pharaon
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens estimèrent qu'il était
regrettable de déranger les morts ils
étaient persuadés qu'une tragédie allait
arriver et essayait de dissuader
d'exhumer le pharaon
[Musique]
car Narbonne Carter et leur équipe
étaient des professionnels il faisait
leur boulot et je ne pense pas qu'il
leur soit venu à l'esprit d'exposer qui
que ce soit face au danger
[Musique]
il ne fallut pas plus de 7 mois Carter
et à son équipe pour extraire la momie
de son sarcophage
ramenez la momie était un travail
éreintant durant l'automne de 1923
l'équipe démolit la cloison principale
du tombeau et procéda au démantèlement
des 4 énormes tombeau de bois qui
contenaient le sarcophage
[Musique]
avec une grande excitation j'ai retiré
les verrous des dernières portes elles
se sont doucement ouvertes et dedans se
trouvaient un immense sarcophage jaune
avec le couvercle solidement fixé ce qui
est spécialement saisissant c'était les
mains tendues d'une déesse sculptée au
pied du sarcophage comme pour repousser
un intrus
si Carter avait tenu compte des
avertissements il aurait interprété cela
comme la quatrième et dernière menace
mais Carter n'y croyait pas
il était sur le point de découvrir l'un
des plus grands mystères de tous les
temps en recueillant le corps de Pharaon
de 3000 ans il pourrait dévoiler les
secrets des anciennes croyances de la
vie après la mort
dans sa précipitation il a fait une
série d'erreurs et des violations
fatidiques
imaginons un système de poulie Carter
souleva le couvercle du sarcophage de
pierre qui révéla le premier des trois
cercueils
le troisième cercueil lui coupa le
souffle fait en or massif il était
décoré pour ressembler au jeune roi
étendu à l'intérieur
anxieusement Carter ouvra le troisième
cercueil les yeux noirs perçant d'un
masque doré le regard est fixement le
masque recouvrait la tête de la momie
royale
[Musique]
plus de 3000 ans se sont écoulés depuis
que les yeux de cet homme fixaient le
vide dans ce cercueil d'or à l'intérieur
se trouve tout ce qui reste du jeune
pharaon
l'irréparable était accomplie le sommeil
paisible du pharaon avait été violé
les bandelettes qui recouvraient la
momie étaient enduit d'une substance
épaisse et noire comme de la résine au
lieu de procéder lentement et de faire
des tests pour savoir de quelle matière
il s'agissait et quel était le meilleur
moyen de l'enlever Carter à la trop vite
il n'a pas suivi les protocoles
scientifiques selon le résultat des
experts il a ravagé le corps de la momie
dans un premier temps Carter exposa la
momie au soleil caniculaire d'Egypte
provoquant la dégradation des
bandelettes puis le docteur Douglas
Derry écarter pour effectuer l'autopsie
ont décidé de couper le corps du pharaon
au lieu de le laisser intact
apparemment leur première priorité au
lieu de préserver le corps était
d'atteindre les objets précieux qui
étaient dissimulés dans les bandelettes
recouvrant la momie selon les rapports
écrits par Derry il semble qu'il n'est
pas craint d'extirper les membres et de
couper le corps jusqu'au tronc
beaucoup de personnes considèrent cet
investigation comme étant à la base du
sacrilège et ils estiment que le roi
n'aurait pas dû être dérangé mais
laissez les pilleurs de tombes vider les
sarcophages alors que ceux-ci sont
intactes ce n'est pas une solution non
plus pour procéder à la séparation du
masque et de la momie Carter et déris
ont utilisé des couteaux brûlants ils
ont démembré la momie en la divisant en
trois parties et en laissant des grands
trous béants entre les articulations au
bout du compte le corps de la momie fut
détruit
ces détails ont été cachés au grand
public
donc le fait que Derry découvrit une
marque sur la joue gauche de la momie le
fut aussi
la momie de Toutankhamon lorsqu'elle a
été examinée par Douglas Derry
paraissait présenté une blessure
d'origine ulcéreuse je pense sur la joue
juste devant le lobe de l'oreille
les gens disent que cette blessure était
au même endroit que la piqûre de
carnaval c'était un signe une
caractéristique particulière
une caractéristique particulière que des
gens ont cité comme une preuve
supplémentaire de la malédiction
mais si la malédiction existe qu'elle
devait être les victimes visées
dans l'année qui suivit la découverte
initiale du pharaon Toutankhamon
beaucoup d'hommes mêlés aux fouilles
trouvèrent la mort
Arthur Maye le bras droit de Carter
celui qui l'a aidé à ouvrir la tombe et
qui a arraché les derniers blocs de mur
pour rentrer dans le tombeau principal
se plaignait d'épuisement progressif
un jour en avril de l'année 1928 il
tombe mystérieusement dans un profond
coma et meurt
le roi américain des chemins de fer
George et Gould décida de visiter
l’egypte après la mort de son vieil ami
Lord carnaval
le matin ou Carter l'emmena au tombeau
il fut foudroyé par la fièvre et mourut
le jour même
l’egyptologue français George Bénédicte
est mort en mars 1926 à la suite d'une
chute après avoir vu le tombeau
[Musique]
l'industriel britannique John whole
succomba à une forte fièvre après sa
visite sur le Site
[Musique]
le radiologue archibal Douglas raid qui
fait des rayons X sur la momie souffre
d'une étrange attaque et mourut peu de
temps après
et en novembre 1929 le secrétaire de
Carter Richard Bettel mourut également
dans les circonstances étranges la
panique se propagea en moins de 6 années
de fouilles à peu près 22 personnes
impliquées dans la découverte du tombeau
du pharaon tout en canon sont mortes
prématurément et subitement
13 des victimes avait fait partie des
personnes qui ont ouvert le tombeau
plusieurs d'entre elles avaient un
rapport indirect avec les fouilles
quand le père de Richard Bettel a pris
la mort de son fils il sauta des sept
étages de l'immeuble où ils vivaient
[Musique]
sur le chemin du cimetière le corbillard
qui transportait son corps heurta et toi
un petit garçon de 8 ans
les dyalmina la femme du défunt Laure
carnaval déclara que son mari avait été
tué par la piqûre d'un insecte
les gens étaient à l'armée par les
nouvelles et craignait que la mort de
tous ces hommes et femmes ne soient pas
dû à la malchance cela devait être la
preuve de la malédiction il croyait
clairement que le pharaon se venait de
la profanation de son corps
[Musique]
en 1930 s'étend après l'ouverture du
tombeau du pharaon Toutankhamon 22
personnes associées à cette découverte
était morte pendant un moment l'histoire
de ces morts enta les fouilles
mais beaucoup de travail restaient
encore à accomplir la nécessité de
cataloguer et de préserver les milliers
d'objets représentait un travail long et
fastidieux les collègues ont remarqué
que World Carter paraissaient malades et
faibles bien qu'il déclara avoir des
difficultés à prendre des décisions et
qu'il souffrait de perte de mémoire sa
place dans l'histoire était déjà assurée
il serait toujours inscrit dans la
mémoire comme l'un des plus célèbres
archéologues de tous les temps les
grands trésors qu'il a découvert serait
bientôt transférés dans le musée du
Caire où il serait exposé en permanence
après les autopsies au rayon X qui la
subit le corps du pharaon tout en Camon
a été réassemblée et remis dans sa tombe
dans la Vallée des Rois
après plusieurs années la malédiction
s'estompe
3D 4 plus tard à la fin des années 60 le
musée du Caire et les autorités
égyptiennes ont commencé à planifier une
exposition des trésors à travers le
monde
parmi ces merveilles ce qui intéressait
les gens c'était l'attirance de la magie
le secret les diffamations etc
l'histoire de cette malédiction n'a
jamais été oubliée et recommença à faire
parler d'elle
les mystères du pharaon Toutankhamon
commencèrent à resurgir ils
accompagnèrent l'exposition à travers le
monde en 1966 le gouvernement égyptien
accepta d’exposer les trésors à Paris le
directeur des Antiquités Mohamed ibraham
réva qu'il courrait un grave danger s'il
est 13h quittaient l'Égypte il implora
un changement de décision
en quittant la dernière réunion avec les
autorités heurté par une voiture il est
mort dans les deux jours six ans plus
tard en 1972 son successeur le docteur
Gamal maire mouru à l'âge de 52 ans le
jour même le masque d'or du pharaon
Toutankhamon était emballé afin d'être
expédié à Londres le même jour le
président des entrepreneurs qui
organisait l'exposition au Musée
britannique de Londres mourut
soudainement
toutes les personnes qui travaillaient à
cette exposition avaient pour ordre de
se taire à propos de cet incident
nous savions qu'un grand nombre de
visiteurs allaient venir et qu'il y
avait une grande probabilité que durant
les 9 mois d'exposition quelqu'un
pouvait se tuer en tombant dans les
galeries
les rumeurs concernant la malédiction
était bien présentes même si le corps du
pharaon a été replacé dans sa tombe
plusieurs personnes ont conclu que le
pharaon ne serait pas en paix tandis que
ces possessions par adresse à travers la
planète il pensait que son voyage dans
l'au-delà avait été interrompu
les anciens Égyptiens croyaient en la
vie après la mort les paysans pouvaient
s'attendre à une simple existence dans
l'au-delà les pharaons étaient supposés
rejoindre le dieu des paradis le dieu
soleil
avec l'aide de la magie le pharaon était
capable de négocier son chemin à travers
le monde souterrain dominant les esprits
du diable et les forces hostiles qui
gardaient les 12 portes de la nuit
[Musique]
des grands prêtres des magiciens prirent
grand soin de préserver le corps du
pharaon et s'assurer qu'il était entouré
les objets nécessaires à son périlleux
voyage
[Musique]
chaque objet correspondait à un but
précis plusieurs de ses objets comportés
des inscriptions mystiques
la tombe de Toutankhamon est remplie
d'inscription presque tous les objets
comporte un écrit spécifique
plusieurs de ces inscriptions sont des
incantations magiques pour protéger le
roi
sur une amulette trouvée dans les
bandelettes qui recouvrent la momie est
inscrite
sort de cette défaillance dans laquelle
tu te trouves tu vas vaincre tout le mal
qui a été fait à ton encontre le masque
d'or porté par le pharaon Toutankhamon
était orné d'image du cobra divin une
déesse protectrice les Égyptiens
croyaient qu'elle crachaient du feu sur
les ennemis du pharaon
dans tout ce qu'on trouve il peut y
avoir des choses symboliques cela ne
veut pas dire que tout est symboles mais
on peut différencier le symbolisme dans
la plupart des éléments spécialement
dans les objets décoratifs et les bijoux
les amulettes par exemple sont toujours
emblématiques
la magie et le symbolisme étaient
fondamentaux pour les anciennes
croyances mais est-ce que cette croyance
en la magie prouve l'existence de la
malédiction
dans le langage des Égyptiens les
malédictions étaient populaires bien
avant la découverte du tombeau du
pharaon Toutankhamon les tablettes
avertissent que ce n'existence a été
découverte à plus d'une occasion l'un
des avertissements les plus claires a
été trouvé dans l'antichambre de la
pyramide
l'esprit de la mort va tordre le cou au
pire de tombe de la même façon qu'à une
oie les égyptologues disent que
l'épreuve que les malédictions étaient
placées dans des tombes appartenant à
des individus existent mais insistent
aussi sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas de
preuve concernant la malédiction du
pharaon certaines inscriptions de
l'Égypte ancienne vont dans ce sens ce
qui laisse à penser que les malédictions
étaient faites pour mettre en garde les
éventuelles pilleurs de tombeau
celle-ci n'était pas habituelle
en fait une malédiction se trouvait dans
chaque tombe égyptienne
depuis bien longtemps des inscriptions
existaient dans les tombes de l'ancien
royaume
le visiteur était prié de ne pas
endommager le tombeau et d'offrir des
présents à la personne décédée
s'il lui arrivait d'endommager la tombe
il pourrait être victime de sérieuses
mais aventures mais aucun texte de ce
genre n'existe dans la tombe du roi
Toutankhamon
[Musique]
ces arguments ont un peu dissuadé les
gens mais beaucoup pensent qu'il serait
possible qu'une malédiction existe et
qu'elle aurait été formulées par les
anciens prêtres pour en être convaincu
il n'y a qu'à compter les morts
[Musique]
les rumeurs concernant la malédiction du
pharaon ont circulé dans le monde entier
depuis la découverte de la tombe du
pharaon tout en Camon en 1922 certains
pensent que la malédiction existe encore
silencieusement et leur magazine sont
pouvoir tant des embuscades en attendant
de frapper sa prochaine victime
aujourd'hui les fouilles d'au moins une
tombe de la Vallée des Rois soit en
cours
en 1989 dans le cadre d'un projet sur la
rivouest du Nil l'archéologue américaine
kentwix relocalisa l'entrée d'une tombe
longtemps délaissée dans la Vallée des
Rois
[Musique]
la redécouverte d'une tombe ne nous
suffisait pas nous avions décidé de
fouiller l'intérieur afin de voir ce
qu'elle renfermait
pendant les six années suivantes Wix et
son équipe ont fouillé les deux
premières pièces du tombeau connu sous
le nom de KV5 c'était le tombeau de 48
princes les filles du pharaon Ramsès II
[Musique]
le tombeau a été dépouillé durant
l'Antiquité les recherches n'ont pas
permis de découvrir des richesses comme
celles trouvées dans la tombe de
Toutankhamon ni aucune preuve d'une
quelconque malédiction
[Musique]
ce qu'ils ont trouvé était ce qu'on
trouve habituellement dans toutes les
anciennes tombes en Égypte un
environnement sombre et humide un
terrain propice aux moisissures
les moisissures peuvent se développer
n'importe où vous pouvez en trouver dans
les sens certaines d'entre elles se
développent dans les eaux humains elles
apparaissent aussi sur la lentille d'un
appareil photo que nous avons utilisé
aujourd'hui
pour se développer la moisissure a
besoin d'un environnement humide et
d'une perpétuelle source de nourriture
la tombe de Toutankhamon est idéale dans
un premier temps il y a l'humidité
régulièrement la Vallée des Rois est
inondé l'eau c'est infiltrée dans les
corridors remplissant chaque cavité du
sol au plafond
deuxièmement il y a la source
alimentaire sous la forme des peintures
murales et des offrandes enterrées avec
le pharaon
les scientifiques ont identifié plus de
80 000 sortes de moisissures dont une
petite quantité provient du corps humain
mort
une de ces moisissures a été détectée
dans un tombeau royal de la Vallée des
Rois l'un des germes est connu sous le
nom de Aspergillus
quiconque entra dans la tombe du roi
tout en Camon a été exposé à des
colonies de germes d'aspergilius qui
recouvraient les murs
[Musique]
qui rentrent facilement dans les poumons
dans la plupart des cas si vous inhalez
ces sports vous pouvez avoir une
réaction allergique
vous pouvez éternuer
tousser peut-être même avoir des maux de
tête mais si le germe se développe dans
les poumons alors les symptômes risquent
d'être plus important
des difficultés à respirer cracher du
sang des congestions mais dans certains
cas les gens peuvent survivre et vaincre
le mal
en tant qu'être humain nous sommes tout
le temps exposé à des formes mortelles
de sport d'Aspergillus il se forme dans
nos jardins quand nous agitons les
sports en ratissant les feuilles ou en
baissant le jardin nous libérons ces
sports dans l'air et les respirons par
inadvertance
les personnes en bonne santé ne sont pas
affectées par les sports les personnes
ayant un système immunitaire faible sont
plus facilement infectés les sports
envahissent la paroi pulmonaire et cause
de graves infections qui se terminent
par la mort
d'après ce que j'ai compris car Narbonne
était prédisposé je suppose que s'il a
inhalé des sports d'Aspergillus ou d'une
autre espèce il a pu en mourir
il y a dû y avoir une période
d'incubation ce n'est pas venu
instantanément cela peut prendre des
semaines ou des mois
il semblait logique que l'ordre
carnarbon qui avait une maladie
pulmonaire soit mort après avoir respiré
ses sports
[Musique]
les symptômes de sa pneumonie étaient
constants il est difficile d'expliquer
la mort des autres victimes même si
plusieurs d'entre elles sont mortes
brutalement après avoir visité le
tombeau les scientifiques s'inclinent
devant le fait que la théorie biologique
est une explication plausible pour
certains des décès
je pense que la prolifération de
moisissure est probablement vrai mais la
question posée est combien de temps
ont-elles persisté se sont-elles
développées au point de devenir un fléau
c'est malheureusement une sport
particulière qui a survécu jusqu'au 20e
siècle depuis l'enterrement du pharaon
tout en Camon grâce à un apport
perpétuel de nourriture la famille
originale de germes a dû être capable de
se reproduire en formant de nouvelles
sports pour que celle-ci puisse
traverser des milliers d'années
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose que nous devons
prendre en compte en effet si vous
travaillez dans une tombe dans un espace
réduit avec des momies vous devez
probablement porter un masque et des
gants c'est juste une question de bon
sens
peut-être est-ce du bon sens aujourd'hui
mais ce n'était pas le cas à l'époque
les archéologues modernes sont bien
attentifs aux possibilités de
contamination sur les sites où il
travaille ils affirment prendre les
précautions nécessaires c'est la raison
pour laquelle aucune des personnes ayant
fouillé le tombeau Cavé 5 n'est tombé
malade ou nez morte
durant des années avant la découverte du
tombeau de Toutankhamon les histoires
sur les malédictions des momies étaient
connus aux USA et en Europe de l'Ouest
lorsque le Titanic prit la mer lors de
son premier voyage en 1912 en plus des
200200 passagers et du fret de
commercial le vaisseau transportait une
momie égyptienne
[Musique]
pour son voyage à travers l'Atlantique
la momie était bien rangée dans une
caisse en bois derrière le pont de
commandement
les survivants interrogés ont déclaré
que le capitaine edwardiste marin hors
pair se comportait bizarrement
il fit route vers une mystérieuse
direction à une vitesse alarmante
lorsque le 15 avril le Titanic entra en
collision avec l'iceberg il attendit
jusqu'à la dernière minute avant de
déclarer le plan d'évacuation
car arrive-t-il à ce capitaine
expérimenté pendant l'accomplissement de
toutes ces erreurs certains pensent
qu'il a été victime de la malédiction de
la momie d'autres disent qu'il a été
infecté par des bactéries cachées dans
les bandelettes de la momie
nous ne serons jamais ce qui a poussé le
Titanic à heurter c'est iceberg
certains s'en tiendront toujours à
l'idée que le destin du bateau était
d'être attiré au fond de l'océan par la
malédiction d'une momie le fait de
croire en la malédiction fait partie du
mysticisme de l'Égypte ancienne
les scientifiques égyptiens certifient
que la malédiction des pharaons n'existe
pas et rejettent franchement la notion
de la malédiction associée au tombeau du
pharaon tout en Camon
est en l'une des personnes qui a porté
l'un des plus importants objets de la
tombe le superbe est fameux masque d'or
que j'ai tenu dans mes mains je suppose
que j'aurais dû être exposé à la
malédiction si le masque regardait dans
ma direction
mais heureusement il regardait dans une
autre direction
je ne crois pas en cette malédiction
il n'y a aucun rapport entre la tombe de
Toutankhamon et une ancienne malédiction
si les gens veulent croire aux
malédictions c'est dans leur tête et
dans le cas de la tombe de Toutankhamon
c'est un conte moderne
les gens ont toujours attribué à
l'Égypte et à l'Égypte ancienne toutes
sortes de pouvoir mystiques qui petit à
petit sont oubliés par les générations
futures
mais rien dans les textes de cette
époque-là ne permet de soutenir la
notion de malédiction comme la supposée
malédiction de Toutankhamon
les historiens prétendent que les
soi-disant avertissements trouvés sur la
tombe ne sont quand même
il se trouve en particulier que Carter a
toujours déclaré ne pas croire à cette
malédiction et justement Carter a vécu
jusqu'en 1939 27 ans après la découverte
de la tombe Harry Burton le photographe
de l'expédition mourut un an après lui
de glace Derry vécue jusqu'en 1969
atteignant l'âge respectable de 87 ans
si la malédiction avait fait ce qu'elle
prétendait ces trois hommes auraient
vaincu sa colère
[Musique]
c'est une malédiction à succès et à
échec si le travail avait été fait
proprement elle n'aurait pas eu cet
impact mais les gens veulent croire que
ça s'est passé
nous vivons dans une époque crédule où
le monde est prêt à saisir toute chose
liées au surnaturel
sûrement parce qu'ils veulent apporter
un autre attrait au passé
ceux qui croient à cette malédiction se
demandent toujours pourquoi tant de
personnes s'impliquent dans les fouilles
du défunt pharaon tout en Camon en
sachant qu'il leur restera peu de temps
à vivre pour profiter de leur découverte
la plupart des gens que l'on a dit
mourir suite à la légende de la tombe de
Toutankhamon était des personnes âgées
il n'existe donc aucun aspect à ce livre
dans le fait que ces personnes soient
mortes dans les 10 ans suivant
l'ouverture de la tombe
serait prudent de dire que chaque
personne qui a travaillé dans la Vallée
des Rois va éventuellement mourir mais
il n'y a certainement rien qui prouve
qu'il y a une malédiction
les gens qui travaillent régulièrement
dans la vallée ont l'habitude de parler
des malédictions
parfois les événements sont assez
étranges pour le devenir encore plus
chez les crédules
durant une fouille l'archéologue
égyptien Zaïa dit avoir reçu des
nouvelles désastreuses chaque fois qu'il
déterrer les antiquités et les rapporter
au musée du Caire
[Musique]
la première fois j'ai appris que mon
oncle était mort l'année suivante
c'était ma tante qui venait de mourir et
la troisième année le même jour quand
j'allais en direction des monuments mon
cousin décède vous faites immédiatement
la relation avec la malédiction et les
gens le pensent mais cet accidentel cela
arrive parfois mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec les monuments
carnaval la première victime avait une
mauvaise santé il était donc incapable
de guérir d'une optomonnaie
[Musique]
c'était un sujet tabou nous étions ma
sœur et moi conviés à ne jamais aborder
ce sujet je suis sûr qu'il y avait une
malédiction mais en même temps je pense
qu'elle n'a pas affecté mon grand-père
en sachant ce que nous savons
aujourd'hui d'où vient la notion de
malédiction et pourquoi prend-elle des
proportions mythiques
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens disent que c'est le
public qui veut simplement croire en la
magie et au mystère d'une ancienne
culture
d'autres pensent que tout a commencé
avec le reporter Arthur wegen et sa
prédiction de la mort de Lord
karnarbonne dans les six semaines
d'autres encore disent que la presse la
alimenter contrariée par l'exclusivité
donnée aux Times de Londres par les
archéologues
et certains disent aussi que c'est
Howard Carter lui-même qui a entretenu
cette légende
peu importe les intentions de Carter le
pharaon Toutankhamon sera toujours
enveloppé du mystère et de la mythologie
de sa malédiction
même si nous avons ces trésors nous ne
savons guère plus sur le pharaon
qu'avant la découverte de sa tombe et
sans doute nous n'en serons jamais plus
personne ne veut t'expliquer pourquoi il
est monté sur le trône aussi jeune et
pourquoi il est mort peu de temps après
[Musique]
la seule chose dont nous sommes sûrs
c'est qu'en 1922 après 3000 ans de
sommeil profond son repos a été
interrompu les trésors ont été emportés
et son corps démembré
[Musique]
peut-être que l'une des raisons qui nous
fascine dans la soi-disant malédiction
du pharaon et ce sentiment de
culpabilité à profaner la mort je suis
sûr que c'est une bonne raison nous
sommes des êtres passionnés nous ne
pouvons pas arrêter cette fascination
mais je pense que quelque part très loin
nous sommes conscients de cette
culpabilité
c'est la culpabilité de l'homme qui
alimente l'histoire de la malédiction ou
bien le besoin de croire en la crainte
et la terreur les anciens pouvoirs
espérons-nous inconsciemment que le
pharaon Toutankhamon peut nous parler de
sa tombe que nous sommes toujours
connectés à sa sagesse et à son autorité
[Musique]
cependant nous avons glané les
connaissances de sa vie à partir de ces
possessions c'est l'esprit du pharaon
tout en Camon et le mystère qui entoure
sa tombe qui nous entra toujours et
restera inexpliqué
[Musique]